welcome to this video playing swag nurse
Carson swag no scars all right from the
US I mean okay the name is not
particularly um yeah you don't really
believe that the guy is really gone like
that so you have a hard time to believe
that the flag is right okay wherever the
Rubenstein Lee knows oh and he's playing
this funny line with Bishop to a five
and as usual I have forgotten my
preparation I think rook be one is what
I had prepared for a toy league game
last year rupee 196 and g3 and i hope
i'm not mistaken there should be seven
FD 585 Bishop g2 yeah I think that yeah
this is what I had looked at but it's so
it's been a while Bishop g2 and now
castles yeah temporarily White has given
up a pawn on c4 but the question is if
the mission on a five and the night on a
six are really good pieces can be a bit
tricky for black okay so the question is
what now i think ii for you for
intending you five is right
it's been a while since I looked there
at this the ideas that I don't really
want to have a piece about I want to
have a piece on d5 and not a pawn so he
takes d5 is not really the idea here
after the night moves I suspect that he
will move the light I can take on d5 and
establish the Queen down yeah this is
what I expected take him and now I have
an ice queen on d5 his sir Knight is a
bit yeah but on its own yeah here on g4
it's not really coordinating well with
the rest of his army and I have the
simple threat at the moment to take on
c4 headwind appease taking the night at
the what okay maybe you can go Queen to
e6 that's possible Queenie six but isn't
this a good position for white query
sixes the only move now i think i'm
attacking g four and a six so he's
probably forced to play Queenie six and
then i thought i would I could I can
just straight but this assessment does
so add this was to be superficial
I'm losing time I thought Queenie six I
just trade the Queen okay yeah I take it
piece is a piece not sure what exactly
is doing check now can denote the bishop
the saying so sorry for my comment I
don't really know what else you should
do okay at least his son governor
checking md5 as possible then I need I
need to get rid of this night maybe a
ticket
yeah I don't see a movie she needs to
retreat the night now and then it very
much feels like piece down for for
absolutely nothing I mean it does feel
like that at the moment already but even
now even more materials really a lot ok
I have the smooth now 97's Sam is the
point he goes to f5 or g 6 97 wins
everything they don't really know well
near him check walking and if he takes
create a second to resign yeah just he
just needs to play 26 somehow him he
didn't didn't spot to move but so the
only one that protects both pieces this
is in fact one issue that black hats in
the slide is sometimes has slightly
loose pieces but this is some certainty
still okay I intended to exchange like
that and their form and I thought maybe
I'm slightly better but when I looked at
it a bit more bitten a bit more detail
it doesn't look like much if anything I
thought those pieces are not really
coordinating ball there this is true
they don't coordinate well but the
question is if it really is enough to to
lead to anything hard to say the precise
son move orders are probably important
him property 8mm
they're probably black should play the
smooth having this idea if he plays a
move like that there is this possibility
and this really puts the night under
some pressure in fact and it's a funny
motif in this kind of structure to play
f5 efg five winning the night I put it
on the board because it's important
let's uh let's say um is playing and not
too much let's say move like that and
then f5 is the idea after the captured
g5 I'm winning the night Black is not
forced to capture obviously but this is
an important tactical idea that you
should keep in mind the night is trapped
if you play g5 immediately there's
always this excellent square and we're
first playing f5 EMG five white make
sure that f5 is no available square so
to avoid any of this black probably
should retreat and after h3 now black
can go here and have this additional
option now yeah the position is only
marginally better for white if anything
so while this is what you should have
done after the other move it's a it's
just a piece for no compensation alright
thanks for watching